and if you watched the debate last night
you may have heard a lot of this if you
think that was distracting you are not
alone CBS moderators have been
criticized for quite a messy debate
joining me now Dave Rubin hosted the
Rubin report and author of the upcoming
book don't burn this book and we
certainly won't we'll have you back to
talk about that you know Fox News when
when we host debates we used a little
bell or a little buzzer that makes it
very clear when somebody's time is up
they didn't have any of that last night
it's always good to be with you you know
that little skirmish you just played
there though that little five seconds I
mean that was basically the most
sensible part of the entire debate I
mean the whole thing is so confusing
right now because the Democratic Party
is splitting into at least two parts
right now perhaps more but at least two
you know you've got sort of the the
socialist progressive lefty far
left-wing which is the Bernie Elizabeth
Warren wing and then you have that least
slightly more moderate somewhat still
liberal more Blue Dog Democrat Bernie
sorry Mike Bloomberg and Biden part of
it but watching them fray and watching
this thing go out of control it's like
these people should not be on stage
together they should be separate parties
at this point and that's why the the
fighting over each other and the
stammering and the and the talking over
each other it's like yeah you guys don't
have a cohesive set of ideas that bring
you together as a party so of course
this is what we're gonna get and as for
the the moderators it's like yeah you
need you need to tell these people to be
quiet and make sure they control
themselves otherwise you end up getting
Joe Biden yelling at everybody with
their fighting for all the marbles right
now because it is crunch time last night
I was watching your Twitter everybody
should follow you on twitter one of the
things that you talked about was that
there was something missing sorry about
that
no I like the Twitter I want to show you
this clip from last night this is Tom
Steyer talking about government and then
I want you to tell people what you
thought was missing from debate the
debate last night watch I don't believe
that a government takeover of
large parts of the economy makes any
sense for working people or for families
I think that what we need to do is to
present an alternative that includes a
vibrant competitive private-sector but
we all know onion capitalism has failed
the answer is not for the government to
take over the private sector though the
answer is for us to break the corporate
stranglehold on our government and have
the government work for the people again
Dave what'd you think of that well
there's nothing like a billionaire
telling me that unchecked capitalism has
failed somehow he managed to do okay in
it but but forget about steyr because
you know his appearance is most people
are sort of pointless I mean look you
yeah you've got you've got the socialist
Bernie and the true capitalist Bloomberg
at each other that's that's the future
of this fight but there's a couple
things going on here I mean when when
steyr and and the rest of them when when
they talk about whatever use the
Democrats believe capitalism still has
the base doesn't care about that they
are socialists and whether you want to
call it socialist or communist or
democratic socialist whatever phrase you
want to use that's fine but that really
is what the base is so when Bloomberg
talks about building a business
successfully when Bloomberg by the way
he actually wore an American flag pin
which I didn't even notice till
afterwards someone pointed out because
the entire thing nobody says anything
positive about America they you know
words like freedom imagine if someone
said the word freedom or Liberty or
anything positive about this incredible
country web what they do is they
constantly tell you how good other
countries are so apparently Sweden and
Denmark it's usually Sweden but Bernie
was big on Denmark last night these tiny
Scandinavian countries with mostly
homogenous populations although now that
in the last five years they've had
immigration they have all sorts of other
problems but they use that as a model
where we in America we've got 350
million some odd people from every walk
of life we've given more freedom to
everybody and somehow they can't even
seem to choke out anything positive
about America and then in the few
moments where Biden who's a little more
old-school he'll say something about the
Constitution and you can almost feel it
in the room that it's like Constitution
what
what we're talking about yes and
everybody should go and check out Dave
Rubens podcast in the youtubes where you
interview the guys from Sweden that talk
about that I thought that was such a
good episode we'd love having you on the
daily briefing hope to have you back
soon Dave Rubin thanks if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell